I looked at a bunch of influencers
who talk about Korean skincare a
lot and tried out some of the products
I saw being recommended over and over
hi it's Michelle of lab muffin beauty
science chemistry PhD cosmetic
chemist and person with skin
Korean skincare is obviously huge right now
there are so many products where do you start?
well, the internet
I looked at a bunch of influencers
who talk about Korean skincare a
lot and tried out some of the products
I saw being recommended over and over
all of these are available on StyleKorean
today's video sponsor here's what I thought
Cosrx Advanced Snail 96 Mucin Power essence is
probably the first product I think
of when I think Korean skin care
so many people in skincare talk about this and
the other snail products from cosrx as well
Jude from 50 Shades of snail has been on this
snail essence train since 2015 and I think a
lot of that Reddit hype was actually from her
even now this pops up on her Instagram at least
once a month James Welsh also always talks
about cosrx snail products in his favorites
so this is just a really solid
product that captures a lot of
the reasons that people tend to
gravitate towards Korean skincare
first off there's this focus on hydration
so East Asian skin tends to be a bit more
easily disturbed in terms of its skin
barrier and there's a lot of aircon in
East Asian countries and so that is a
really good recipe for dehydrated skin
East Asian skincare routines also tend
to have a few more steps and so there's
a lot of products that can deliver this
massive punch of hydration while staying
really lightweight and being really
good to layer with other products
the products are also usually
pretty budget friendly and there
is sometimes an exotic appeal which
is definitely the case with snail
the main ingredient in this is obviously
snail mucin which is also called snail
secretion filtrate so the logic behind
snail slime is this goop is protecting
their belly which I know is technically
called a foot but it feels wrong to call
it a foot let's steal this goop from
the snails and slap it on our skin
the most obvious thing that this immediately
does is hydrate the crap out of your skin
hydration is really the main thing behind that
glowy glass skin look and I think that's why
this product just keeps going viral it's
just really nice instant gratification the
reason it's so good at hydrating is that
snail essence has a really complex mix
of long chain sugary molecules called
glycosaminoglycans and proteoglycans
subscribe to my channel to hear
me pronounce long science words
and these are what gives it that really
stringy texture as well as that super
hydrating effect they're really good at holding
on to water and acting as a humectant moisturizer
aside from hydration this product is also really
known for brightening skin tone helping with
breakouts and irritation and there's some talk of
it being good for anti-aging and wrinkles as well
it's hard to pin any of this down to like a single
substance in the snail essence but it does contain
a lot of antioxidants peptides antimicrobial
compounds and even some glycolic acid cosrx
have also added some extra ingredients that also
add to their super hydrating and soothing effect
I found that on my skin this is just amazing for
really hardcore hydration with a side of soothing
it's a very versatile product you can apply a
thick layer and even then it isn't really sticky
it's more just hydrated and tacky you can mix a
little bit with water for a more thin toner-like
application you can mix it in with a moisturizer
and it works really well for hydrating your skin
just before putting on makeup without leaving like
a layer that might interfere with later products
from my understanding the process of extracting
the mucin for cosrx products doesn't hurt the
snails they crawl over textured material
that collects the mucin in a dark room
and apparently the highest quality mucin is
collected when the snails aren't stressed
snail is a natural extract which means there
is a lot of variation and that includes the
fact that the percentage won't tell you
that much you're going to have different
amounts of the actual compounds within
each extract so if you're looking to try
out a snail product I would recommend
ignoring things like so-called dupes
and percentages and really just focus on
looking at reviews of individual products
also because it's a natural extract
there can be allergens in it and
there are cross reactivities between
snail and dust mites and shellfish
some people get closed comedones which are these
small clogged pores that look like flesh colored
bumps but in general this is a super popular
product that works really well for a lot of
people and I think this is a great first product
if you're just starting out with Korean skin care
the next product is the pyunkang yul essence toner
I first heard about this brand from gothamista
who is like YouTube skincare godmother their
products are really minimalist they focus on
using plant extracts and they're really
designed for people with sensitive skin
to be honest I've kind of been putting off testing
out this brand because I assumed they were really
expensive I just thought these ingredients don't
really have a lot of of independent verification
I'm going to have to dedicate a lot of time to
testing them out really really thoroughly on my
skin to make sure I'm comfortable recommending
something really expensive and then I found out
that they're actually super budget friendly they
just have nice packaging that looks expensive
this essence toner is probably their most
popular product just from the packaging
I assume this would be around the $50
mark it's kind of hard to say because
StyleKorean are always having different sales
but right now this smaller bottle is 5.50 USD
this has astragalus root extract as the
main ingredient it's a herb that's used
in eastern medicine there isn't a
lot of evidence for what it does on
skin but most plant extracts have some
level of humectants which will hydrate
and antioxidants that can soothe skin and
soak up free radicals this specific extract
also has betaine which is soothing
and hydrating as well as minerals
the texture of this is like a thick cushiony
water that's slightly slippery it absorbs
really quickly it's weightless and it
doesn't feel tacky at all on my skin
I found that this was really soothing and
refreshing but I wouldn't say it's really
hydrating compared to other Korean products
I was actually quite disappointed in how
much this kept my skin hydrated throughout
the day it just went away pretty quickly
it is still a lot more hydrating than
most western toners though so I think
it's really what you're looking for if
you have really dehydrated skin and you
want just one hardcore hydrating product in
your routine that keeps your skin plump all
day then this is not it but if you want
something lightweight and soothing and
your skin isn't super thirsty if you want a
hydrating toner for summer or if you use lots
of layers of hydration if you're using like
the seven skins method then this is great
the round lab birch juice moisturizing sun cream
has been hyped up so much it was on both Soo
Beauty and Euniunni's top list of 2021 I've seen
it from Bonnie Garner of beauty alley who does
these really comprehensive sunscreen roundups
sugar peaches loves Alice in the rabbit hole
this is also a sunscreen that's popular with
Korean customers and the tube actually has
almost no English on it so this is
like the hipster Korean sunscreen
this is another one of those chemical
Kolmar sunscreens that has the same core
formula they've been super popular over the last
couple of years and each one just has very slight
variations on a theme if you've been watching
my videos you'll know that this family of Kolmar
chemical sunscreens has been top of my list for
a while they just work really well on my skin
they feel sort of like a cream gel
moisturizer going on they're really
hydrating they also just feel like they
stay on your skin pretty well they are
SPF 50+ pa++++ which is as high as the rating
system goes in Korea they don't leave a white
cast unless you have relatively dark skin
and that white cast probably comes from
the mbbt UV filter which is a chemical
sunscreen but it's in little particles
these do leave a little bit of a
shiny finish so some people find
them quite greasy but for me the
film is just really light and it
falls on the glowy side of like
the glowy slash greasy dichotomy
I think part of that is also just that they
hydrate my skin really well which makes my
oil just feel lighter and my skin ends up
looking better rather than just kind of gross
where this falls on the range I found that this
was slightly heavier and richer than the beauty of
joseon sunscreen so I think this is more suitable
if your skin is drier or if it's slightly drier
weather I found this a bit more hydrating than
the isntree one and it feels a little bit lighter
the actives in this are birch juice which
is meant to be purifying baobab extract and
hyaluronic acid which are hydrating allantoin
which is soothing and also the niacinamide
and adenosine which is standard in all the
chemical sunscreens in this kind of family
having all these very similar Kolmar sunscreens
I've seen Odile Monod say that it's boring and I
do kind of agree but at the same time it is also
really nice to just have all these variations on
my favorite formula if you don't like this
formula or if you're allergic to one of the
components then this is probably much less of a
good time for you but this channel is about me
the mixsoon bean essence is another product
that I heard about from Soo Beauty she uses
this as a hydrating essence she's raved
about it so much that I got it and started
using it just off her recommendation
and then after I'd been using it for
a few weeks I looked at the product page
and came across a video by beauty within
and I found out that you can also use it
as an exfoliant sort of like a peeling
gel you can like massage it on your skin
and get skin off which I was not expecting
this was actually the top voted multifunctional
product of 2021 on glowpick which is a
Korean beauty app this has four fermented
ingredients bean pomegranate barley and pear
that fermented soybean explains the texture
it's really gooey and stringy and it's a lot
like snail slime if you've seen natto
which is like edible Japanese soybeans
you'll know that stringiness and like the
snail slime this texture comes from long
chain hydrating molecules that form a sort
of net over your skin that sticks to water
I'm not 100% sure what the specific compound
is but it should be similar to
natto which has polyglutamic acid
the pomegranate extract is a natural
source of alpha hydroxy acids which
provides some of this exfoliating
effect the other extracts also
have antioxidants vitamins the
standard plant extract benefits
there are a bunch of clinical studies
on this where it's smoothed out texture
helped with blackheads and also reduced skin oil
from the texture you would expect this
to be like really sticky but it isn't
it feels really nice and hydrating on
the skin and it seems to settle down
really quickly I was really impressed
by the hydrating abilities of this I
did sort of feel that hydrating net
even the next day after I woke up
for exfoliating which was is the bit I was most
interested in because I love peeling gels you
prep your skin with warm water pump out some of
the product and just start massaging in circles
then after about a minute you start to feel
these little sand like grains on your skin
of course I wasn't entirely satisfied with that so
I pumped out more product and the massaged it even
more and at about two minutes they were probably
about maybe 50 little grains and these are like
a little bit smaller than really fine sand it is
really satisfying once that starts happening it
happens a lot slower than with a peeling gel which
is pretty immediate there's also a lot less grains
and I collected some of these and looked
at them under a microscope and they looked
really white so I'm thinking most of it is
actually something in the product bunching up
it does make my skin feel super smooth and
soft afterwards more so than with a peeling
gel and I'm not sure if it's because
it is exfoliating more or if it's just
that I've been massaging this hydrating
essence into my skin for three minutes
I do wonder if there are a lot lot of other
products on the market that you can do this
with and they just don't promote themselves that
way but I did try it with the snail essence as
well and I got a few tiny grains after about three
minutes of rubbing and by that point my skin was
feeling really sore and irritated because
it is a lot stickier and yeah you're just
dragging your skin around so I do think this
essence is like the perfect texture for this
onto some beauty of joseon products I've
talked so much about the beauty of joseon
sunscreen but they have a whole line of
other products as well I did give their
serums a bit of a try a while ago but my
pigment and breakouts haven't been that
much of an issue so those products didn't
give me that much benefits because they
didn't target my skin concerns I have
seen tons of raves about them though
the products I tried for this video are
the dynasty cream and their eye serum
with the dynasty cream my main influencer
here was Kelly Driscoll she did a video on
her top beauty of joseon products and this
was in it she's been using this since 2015
this was beauty of joseon's first product and
it's been through a few reformulations since
then it comes in some really nice luxe
packaging so here is an unboxing video
this has a really nice gel cream texture that is
a little bit on the heavier side for a gel going
on it's really lightweight and hydrating and
not at all greasy I found that this is really
good for prepping my skin under makeup and I'm
actually wearing it under my makeup now but for
my dry skin in winter I found that I can just
use a bit more and it still works really well
it features rice bran ginseng and niacinamide
which are all great for hydrating skin there's
also some smoothing and brightening effects
as well there are some really light oils in
there as well like squalane and hydrogenated
polydecene which is sort of similar to mineral oil
it also doesn't have any fragrance which
is a bit unusual for a cream in a jar
with such sort of luxury packaging so if
you're looking for a lightweight hydrating
moisturizer especially one that is fragrance
free then this might be a really good option
I first came across this product which is the
beauty of joseon revive eye serum ginseng and
retinal through Alice in the rabbit hole she
reviews a lot of Korean skincare and beauty
of joseon was actually her favorite brand
of 2021 and this was her favorite product
after I started trying this out I also saw like
a whole flood of reviews come out including
from Dr Dray Cassandra Bankson James Welsh
so maybe there is this sort of artificial
marketing push but I can't really be mad at it
beauty of joseon have been around for so long
and their products are really nice they have
worked hard for their time in the spotlight
I'm a little bit hesitant when I'm trying
out eye creams because I wear ortho K contact
lenses at night and sometimes I'll have to
get out of bed and readjust them so having
greasy stuff around my eyes can really be
annoying for that I'll like kind of lose grip
on the eyelid but I was really excited about
trying this one out because of the ingredients
ginseng is their star ingredient here
they say they included it because it's
been shown to target wrinkles it is
really popular in Korean skincare
there's also retinal with an A and this is
a stronger form of vitamin A that converts
to retinoic acid tretinoin in just one
step and so it is as close to tretinoin
as you can get in a cosmetic product so it
is one step closer than retinol with an O
vitamin A derivatives retinoids are like the
gold standard ingredients in skin care and
retinal with an A has been making its
way into a lot of skin care products
retinal is usually encapsulated in products
and this improves the stability of it this
is really good because retinoids
are kind of notoriously unstable
there was one study that looked at how
much retinol was left in a bunch of
different products and after six months
one of them had degraded by 80 percent
encapsulation also means that the retinal
gets very gradually released onto the skin
you don't just get one massive flood
at the start and so that usually gives
you less irritation but you can
still get similar overall results
sometimes I have a little bit of doubt about
some forms of encapsulation I'm not sure it's
actually releasing all of the retinoid out of the
capsule but I don't think it's a problem for the
main form on the market which is cyclodextrin
or what's used in this which is liposomes
the retinal is at 0.02% which I think is like a
nice low to medium intensity this is one of the
most inexpensive retinal products I've seen
and of course you don't have to just use it
around your eyes on the beauty of joseon
website they actually recommend that you
can use it on the rest of your face and on
other parts of your body too so if you're
looking for like a general retinal product
to try this one is a really good option
you might want to look out for irritation though
I saw Kelly Driscoll mentioned that she got some
irritation on her eyelid with this which isn't
that surprising because strong retinoids do tend
to make you go a bit flaky and go through this
sort of adjustment period as your skin kind of
rebuilds itself I have a video on how to get
through that process with minimal irritation so
if this is going to be your first retinal product
I highly recommend using some of those strategies
so this was a really good batch of products
I think I might have kind of put my thumb
on the scales because I do know what I'm
looking for in products and every time I
was looking for a new recommendation I had
like a mental checklist of what I like and
I was comparing that with what people were
saying in their reviews I think that's a
good strategy in general when you're
looking at reviews of products just
make sure you remember your actual needs
and don't just get swept along by hype
I think the least successful product was
this essence toner and that's just because
it doesn't really suit my style of routine
as much and even then I'm pretty sure I'll
be using this in hot weather when I
get that sort of prickly heat feeling
I hope you enjoyed chatting skincare with me let
me know what your experiences
were like with these products
don't forget to hit the like
and the subscribe to tell the
YouTube algorithm that you want to
see more of this type of content